today is a very happy day as far as I'm
concerned I have seen brought to a safe
and successful conclusion a very
important operation which is the
carrying out of a promise made by the
President of the United States to the
Prime Minister of Japan that we would
remove these weapons from Okinawan soil
that has now been accomplished but most
significantly it was accomplished
completely safely and that was the prime
objective
the purpose of this ceremony today to
pay tribute and also thanks to all of
you who are in formation today with the
members of the 67th Chemical Company
sitting to my left and through you
today more than 1500 people who
participated successfully and one of the
most difficult operations ever
accomplished by the United States
military forces I personally had
extensive opportunity to observe the
dedication to duty the great skill and a
plain old-fashioned hard work which is
performed by all of the people involved
in the operation I have only the highest
praise for all of you and the highest
commendation for your efforts during
peace as well as war an army must
maintain its capability to respond to
any assigned mission Operation Red Hat
removal of toxic chemical munitions from
Okinawa to storage facilities on justin
island exemplify this responsiveness it
was a mission involving meticulous
planning by dedicated men to ensure the
safest most efficient coordination of
mind muscle and machinery the long hours
under a sweltering sun dried up
reservoirs that cause water rationing
the tense political situation the Army's
desire to complete the mission
flawlessly for all part of Operation Red
Hat in 1969 President Richard Nixon told
Prime Minister Eisaku Sato the US would
removed the more than 13,000 tons of
toxic munitions prior to the reversion
of the islands to Japanese control
planning for RedHat began in the fall of
that same year but due to delays in
selecting a suitable storage site was
postponed until January 1971 this type I
am sure to open on soil ever again phase
one of red hat originally scheduled to
began January 11th was delayed two days
at the request of chief executive cho bo
Jana of the government of the Ryukyu
Islands the last high Commissioner James
V leopard to postpone the movement in
order for the gri to work out
last-minute details with the villages
along the route
On January 13 the first convoy moved up
from ciabatta ammunition depot to begin
at 7 mile trip to Tengen pier the second
convoy departed ciabatta on schedule
moving along the route through the
villages of Nevada Kawa ichihara and
anobii without incident loading
operations went without incident
and the ship the u.s. NS James E
Robinson was loaded late that afternoon
and again the voids to justin island
early the next morning planning for
phase 2 which included the construction
of additional storage facilities on
Johnston Island began immediately while
the extensive construction was being
accomplished on Johnston Island that
alternate route was constructed through
the shabana ammunition depot to the
convoys wood for the most part travel on
military controlled land after lengthy
negotiations the new road was
constructed in less than two months with
the Government of Japan paying for the
construction and the u.s. providing the
manpower for the project a joint u.s.
GRI committee of specialists in all
phases of the operation was established
by high commissioner Lampard and chief
executive Yara to coordinate phase 2
operations this committee published a
joint safety plan work to medical
problems established emergency safety
stations and contributed to the
successful completion of the operation
in an effort to come the fears of
military employees working inside
shabana Depot general Hays and mr.
Sackett nakamura representing the u.s.
gri safety committee spoke to employees
and explained the safety precautions
that would be taken strike plans by the
Okinawan employees were cancelled when
they learned of the safety measures in
spite of the exhaustive efforts that
were made to relieve the fears and
anxieties of the Okinawan people living
along the Red Hat route to convince them
that all possible safety precautions
have been taken to protect their
well-being all were not convinced a
demonstration by villagers living along
the route erupted shortly before phase
two was to get underway
no major problems were encountered
strike was averted and Phase two was
ready to get underway the Red Hat
commander addressed the participants his
theme was safety
which is
the red hat area of shabanah a venetian
devil was one of strict security and
closely controlled entrance the mission
of providing security was assigned to
the 267th chemical company commanded by
captain william go for it during phase
two loading operation captain Goforth
traced the company's activities main
function and readout area to 67 is to
package load on trailers and ship to
tend and clear all chemical munitions
store in Japan is defo throwing these
procedures that we go through in order
to do this is the check through our
security gate go straight to a
dispensary check through this entry
come back out have a briefing from our
section sergeants collect our ammunition
inspector take escort representative and
go down to a site the first have to
check the site out with personnel and
full butyl rubber to ensure there is no
leakage inside the igloo by using the
detectors or monitors after we
determined that it is not contaminated
in any way we open the structure up
spotted trailer in front of it and start
loading it further with the electric
forklift
inside and guests working on the outside
after a trailer has been loaded blocked
and braced for the plastic on the
section sergeant will shift the trailer
to the holding area which is inside the
read out area itself with wet Park parks
and placards will be placed upon the
trailer and the convoy scorn
I will pick up the convoy paperwork
escort a convoy out of the read out area
itself through the combo forming or a
period in shabana death or the in the
Red Hat area there are a few men who
stand by the igloos as the pallets are
brought out and they check the pallets
and the munitions over pretty carefully
just what are they looking for
this is the ammunition inspected and
tech escort recommending respecting the
pallet for a good pack loose bands
versus pallets if we find any of their
replaced and repacked on site we're
getting up in a company area now at
around 4:30 in the morning it and
shutting down our operations no later
than 1800 at night
this is a seven-day-a-week proposition
we've worked before for days on one day
out for crews they're working hard
they're doing a good job
the convoy commander accompanied by a
technician from the 267th Chemical
Company escorted loaded trailers from
the Red Hat area to the convoy holding
area near the convoy commander inspected
each trailer to ensure it contain the
proper load of chemical munitions and
that the munitions have been properly
placed on all trucks and trailers and
that the vehicles have been inspected by
technicians from the five 31st
transportation company at the same time
GRI representatives conducted their
safety checks after completion of the
checks the convoy commander briefed
convoy members concerning the route an
emergency procedure should any driver
encounter a problem with his truck
major Donovan Kirkpatrick a convoy
commander
we're trying to be as careful plainly
possible to ensure that there are no
accidents or incidents with issue
everyone has protective glasses I am
wearing here additionally each cargo
bearing vehicle is equipped with a small
hand decontamination unit there are two
decontamination trucks in convoy and
there is technically qualified escort
personnel trained in the decontamination
number the USNS Sealift arrived at Naha
military port approximately a week prior
to the commencement of Phase two for
Shiva colonel Eldon Carey chief of
terminal operations discussed the
reasons for the selection of the sealing
square but it was the primary reason for
selection this ship most of the cargo on
our first shipment will be stowed one
high as opposed to a normal storage for
ammunition where you stack it about as
high as it will go this one high stow
will allow the technical escort people
who will be aboard the ship as it goes
to Johnson Island to have access to and
observe all the ammunition that's aboard
the ship with relative ease emergency
safety stations do constantly monitor
convoy movements and provide evacuation
medical assistance and decontamination
should the need arise were established
by the u.s. GRI Safety Committee these
sites were placed at four strategic
locations along the Red Hat Road with
automatic alarms and micro
meteorological experts standing by on
decontamination vehicles travel of each
convoy other decontamination trucks were
at each emergency station and it
appeared each truck carried a cargo of
decontaminates be used should the
unexpected occurred a special technical
escort team from Edgewood Arsenal
accompany each convoy only once was the
tech escort team called upon perform its
task and then it was done only as a
precautionary measure while the fourth
ship the sea lift was being loaded a
pallet containing 15 rockets drop from a
height to 40 feet into the hole in the
ship although the impact caused the
Rockets to scatter about
was no leak of personal injury after an
inspection of the rockets the tech
escort team placed them at airtight
containers when the journey to justin
island its convoy followed a set
procedure for entry under the route
after clearing the holding area
clearance to cross checkpoint 1 and
checkpoint 2 was granted by the airborne
control officer for clearance to be
granted no aircraft preparing to land or
takeoff at Kadena Air Base could cross
over the route while the convoy was
moving therefore direct communication
between Kadena tower and the airborne
control officer was a must at the
intersection of Highways 13 and 24 many
visitors observed the convoys daily each
morning when convoys were scheduled High
Commissioner Leppard observed the
operation along with chief executive
Jana and other high-ranking gri
officials at throughout the day other
senior officers from both neosaurus and
the second logistical command observed
convoys from this vantage point
Lieutenant Colonel Harry Bailey the
commanding officer of the 196 ordnance
battalion who was directly responsible
for the activities within the Red Hat
area discussed the operation from the
standpoint of planning the 196 ordinance
which Simon has been involved for well
over a year and a half we could reflect
back even further than that because we
were the recipient of the munitions from
there were person to the island 1963
1965 time period but insofar as the
removal of the munitions is concerned
the battalion has actively participated
for about a year and a half of course my
predecessor from the corridor before the
chief planners involved in the project
and was the architect for the first move
of the nine trailers that we call the
phase one though
13 in January this year all of my
companies had a bit of the action of
course the 267th chemical company is the
principal participant that they've had
the responsibility for for loading the
munitions of checking the munitions
before loading and they worked long
hours and getting the trailers ready for
the move but we've had other
participants to conventional ammunition
workers from the 175th ammunition
company that manages conventional duck
mo that participated by producing for
tour by sending us on the 37 bodies to
assist in the work of the 267th our EOD
detachment 450 we the only detachment is
standing back through the pipe people
great at all the time to participate the
case of emergency
Captain Jack Evans his commanding
officer in the five thirty first
transportation company it was his
drivers who piloted their trucks from
jovanna Depot to ten Ganthier 150
drivers were used for the mission one
half hour was used to transit the route
from Shabana to tengan this was because
of the speed limit restrictions that
were placed on us for safety we were
concerned mainly with the maintenance in
the morale aspect with maintenance it
was very time-consuming making sure all
safety items were checked as for the
morale a few of the items that we tried
for the individuals for their benefit
tracer morale was the Red Hat pin which
you see some of the drivers are wearing
the Red Hat themselves and the emblem
that's placed on the front of their
vehicles and shaven red head each
evening following the final convoy the
Red Hat task force staff made it the
second logistical command field
headquarters here Jennifer Hayes and his
staff reviewed the day's operations and
prepared the convoy schedule for the
following day
many subjects were discussed including
whether public affairs maintenance
convoy operations and loading progress
trucks arriving at Tengen pier and
assigned positions on the causeway
while waiting to be called forward for
the unloading process as they were
called forward by the pier crew a
technical escort team met each one
inspecting them to ensure there had been
no damage to the man
during the seven mile ride from Shobana
following this peer workers prepare the
trailer for unloading by removing the
travelin and plastic covering forklifts
then moved the pallets of bombs Rockets
boat containers mines mortars and
artillery projectiles to the loading
area once in the ship
another forklift was used to move the
munitions to their storage area major
george jackson deputy appear officer
spoke about the mission the heat and the
performance of the men on the pier and
in the hold of the ships we've had a
task force assembled within the director
transportation operation composed the
part of the Army civilians military
personnel we have had additional advice
coordination from the Coast Guard
representatives from Navy personnel
cno's office and from representatives of
the department army tech escort team
primarily of chemical officers and NCOs
and here for the movement of those
munitions under the safest of condition
is equal to or greater than those
requirements in don ôt united states own
Tengen pair itself and on the ship we
have the four twelve terminal service
company which is located here on Okinawa
it's a permanent unit here
329 personnel I was commanded by captain
Ralph Lewis as such he provides me the
stevedores to work the ship or include
winch operators hatch Foreman had the
stevedores and I hope these kids the
ones that have taken the brunt of this
heat we're pumping a lot of water to him
and we've only had one man that's had a
dehydration problem so far in the first
six days of the operation the hot
doesn't get down there it can get up to
about 110 degrees if you have no free
we've been very fortunate last three
days and had a good breeze captain Ralph
Lewis the commanding officer of the 412
terminal service company discussed the
performance of his men during the 38
days loading operations were in progress
and it rises about four o'clock in the
morning they're out to about 1800 at
night and
that doesn't be too much time just an
island a 700-acre ATO located 750 miles
southwest of Hawaii was worthless
zealand the first ship to participate in
phase 2 docked at one time an emergency
airstrip this small island was selected
to house the 13,000 tons of munitions
being moved from okinawa work began
immediately and since the storage area
was but a mile from the dock the
offloading procedures moved along quite
rapidly small convoys escorted by tech
escort personnel moved back and forth
between the new RedHat area and the dock
and a dawn to dusk operation majority of
munitions were placed in small metal
warehouses with the more hazardous
missions such as rockets being placed in
bucker constructions critical monitoring
of munitions also took place on justin
island with take air support personnel
checking every pallet and truckload of
munitions as was done in okinawa all
safety procedures for securing the
pilots to the trucks were accomplished
in a safe and expeditious manner I will
give you a categorical complete
statement that every round of toxic
chemical munitions stored on Okinawa has
now been removed the last of them are on
that ship right there this action today
completes the land phase of Operation
Red Hat involving the removal from
Okinawa of the toxic chemical munitions
which have been in storage here I want
to say that I think that the fact that
we were able to carry out this operation
so successfully and as we had said
that have not interfere with we could
assure that it could be done safely is a
tribute to the cooperation that we
received from the many people in the GRI
government and elsewhere here on Okinawa
the United States will never initiate
the use of chemical warfare
we have renounced completely the use of
biological warfare we are prepared to
use toxic chemical weapons in
retaliation only against a nation which
may use them against us
the morning after general Hays press
conference jennipher leopard general
Hays Colonel Bailey at an official party
including Japanese ambassador to kasi
and chief executive Yana went to
ciabatta Depot for a joint inspection of
the empty igloo first time in a number
of months I did start a reflection on
the whole operation and what it's mapped
to me since the back in July 1969 when
the headlines in The Wall Street Journal
on a Friday morning put the Pentagon in
an uproar over the fact that the toxic
munitions were stored on Okinawa and the
political uproar that came out of that
and subsequent to that the decision of
the president and the promise that he
made to the Prime Minister of Japan that
the United States would remove all toxic
chemical munitions from Okinawan soil
and this became Operation Red Hat so how
did Operation Red Hat get dubbed that
actually it goes way back to 1962
I was then the deputy commander at
Edgewood Arsenal and we were under a
very highly classified operation
instructed to ship these chemical
munitions to Okinawa at that time
because it was such a highly
fight operation it required a code name
and we went to the Pentagon to the
assistant chief of staff for
intelligence who handles all code words
and assigns them and nearly asked for a
code name which would not be of any
significance to the movement of toxic
munitions and someone in the Pentagon in
the lexicon that we used to use in
Washington probably some little old lady
in tennis shoes reached an inherent gave
the words Red Hat at the time the
meaning of Red Hat was very highly
classified and it was really never
revealed until 1969 when we began the
removal of them and we just kept the
same name you might like to mention a
few of the unit's and some of the
commanders that are under your control
that helped move this in a very highly
safe manner well I think that the great
bulk of the credit goes to the enlisted
men and the company officers of the 267
Chemical Company the 530 first
transportation company and the 412 port
company these three units aided by the
rest of the personnel on the second
logistical command and a number of other
units here on Okinawa bore the brunt of
this removal operation it has been an
example however of joint inter-service
cooperation which brought people here to
Okinawa from all over the world so I
would have to mention a number of
personnel and units detachments that
came from the Army Navy and Air Force to
support this operation and I shouldn't
forget the Coast Guard either
sike I believe in our convoys we had two
Air Force sergeants right in the fire
truck almost every day's all right
that's correct and as I ran the airborne
control it was those tower men at Kadena
Air Base who gave me all the advisories
which permitted us to have the convoys
friends at the route carefully without
interfering aircraft the ceiling of the
USNS Francis X McGraw on September 10th
brought to a close the most successful
operation ever accomplished by the
United States Army Ryukyu Islands and in
particular the men of
second logistical command more than 1500
people were directly involved in the
planning and execution of the operation
Air Force controllers at getting at our
Coast Guard building experts on the ship
u.s. Navy technicians on the pier
specialist embracing and blocking from
the United States forklift operators and
many more a magnitude of the operation
from just the viewpoint of the total
number of convoys is attribute to the
planners and the doozers including phase
one one thousand two hundred and twenty
two trailers made the journey from
Shabana ammunition depot to ten gampy
this operation completed so successfully
is a story of the men who wore the red
hat and were in fact the very pulse of
Red Hat